bon alors on va y aller la gloria parce
que maintenant c'est le moment important
où tu as été marié dix fois on va
essayer des neuf va essayer d'y voir
clair
on va prendre part à ce que tu veux bien
aller en piste alors le premier
s'appelait guillermo tejero c'est
vraiment s'il te plaît quoi s'il te
plaît celle de la cellule à oublie le
parce que je suis malade seulement à la
à me rappeler
serge ans de carrière oui on la quitte a
fait des trois enfants ou oui on va ce
sujet trois accidents que j'adore alors
le deuxième c'est vrai alors je ne sais
pas
c'est vrai qu'il s'appelait maurice que
c'était sans un prêt de ton d'imprésario
âge il a vécu avec ton pognon jusqu'à sa
mort j'en sais rien moi jamais je n'ai
jamais posé nos à bon non il était déjà
marié ouais et je ne savais pas oui oui
je le suis parce que j'ai trouvé un jour
un petit message de sa son épouse d'un
sa veste
le troisième c'était ton coiffeur claude
et c'est vrai qu'il a surpris un jour
avec un garçon oui il des papillons
or le quatrième alors là par contre on y
arrive ça c'est le pire ça c'est jean
mixel français c'est de là on le laisse
gens mais dis moi c'est pas lui qui a
épousé pierrette le pen depuis non un
petit ange non il n'a pas épousé non
plus non non il lui a fait faire un
livre
il a fait un livre je crois et il a fait
poser nue
dans playboy le cinquième il s'appelle
ernesto c'est ça c'est un chef
ouais sa guitare in life et j'ai bien
amour tu ne regrettes tu sais ce que tu
as l'air de regretter jusqu'à maintenant
le sixième il s'appelait daniel et c'est
vrai g8 et qu'on lit alors le septième
sais pas si c'est vrai il était toréador
et garder les oreilles au frigo oui non
l'égard des pauvres rio mais c'était une
véritable massacre
alors il partait il partait dans ces
deux courses de taureaux d'ailleurs ces
patchs et pas tenable
oui et le 8e et le 9e j'avoue que j'ai
pas d'information je t'écoute c'était
qui le 8ème c'était un c'était nicolas
nicolas
il ay l'abbé il a 24 ans et puis ça
marche très bien c'était formidable on
s'entendait très bien s'amuser bien on
travaillait très bien et tout ça mais un
jour il m'a sorti qu'il voulait des
enfants
le neuvième c'était salvador c'est ça
salvat dans l'oubli et ce non seulement
dont c'est un gentil garçon qui est venu
avec dedans avec moi du mexique avec
lequel j'étais marié sept ans et puis il
est arrivé ici en france et puis les
femmes françaises merveilleuse mais à un
jour j'ai reçu un coup de fil me disant
à loos chez madame
face au oui écoutez je vous appelle avec
une loi comme ça je vous attendent parce
que vous savez je suis très malheureuse
ah bon oui est-ce que je suis mme bah
écoutez je suis l'ami de salvador je dis
une fois bouger je peux vous est utile à
quelque chose c'est bien parce que je
voulais savoir si vous allez divorcer
mais voilà une information
si vous tes vous dit que vous l'aimez
beaucoup que vous êtes très amoureuse
oui enfin je vous les donne et jacques
rocher le téléphone et puis salvador est
arrivé le soir il a trouvé ces malisan
la porte et il m'a dit tu pars en voyage
non chérie chez toi qui pas bon alors
qu'en première annonce c'était un
médecin qui est mort pendant la guerre
d'espagne et s'y était pas mort soit
être était une femme très fidèle et tu
serais marie qu'une seule fois finançons
suis fidèle
oui c'est vrai tu te maries souvent mais
quand et marité fidèles c'est vrai je
suis fidèle je quitte les maris lorsque
je vois que que ça ne marche plus parce
que je considère qu'il est parfaitement
inutile est même malhonnête d'iroise
malhonnête de rester avec un homme comme
ça ne marche plus comme l'un plus haut
que l'homme ne vous aime plus je trouve
que c'est
c'était comme moi de dire oui je reste
avec mon mari parce que vous comprenez
il ya tellement d'intérêts au milieu
et ensuite après on lui fout des cornes
tous les jours pendant non franchement
di maria est ce que le soir avant de
t'endormir tu tu t'endors en contenter
mari comme c'est ce que tu tues tu
repenses alors c'est quoi le problème
avec les hommes c'est que ils refusent
tous en fête avec tes mari refuse tout
d'être monsieur gloria lasso c'est ça le
problème finalement oui et tu sais c'est
à matic parce que je peux te dire le
processus c'est tous les mêmes ouais
c'est jamais problèmes sexuels non est
ce que à ce que je note quand même parce
que là on va voir un petit sujet sur
quelqu'un qui a eu un problème à cause
de son sexe là est ce que c'est
est ce que pour toi qui a connu beaucoup
de marie est ce que la taille du sexe de
l'homme est importante
ce n'est pas important et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux